[Music]
at this month's council meeting for
September a moving tribute was made by
mere ears for Peter Ellen who sadly
passed away this last week Peters
passing is a huge loss for our community
by the privilege of working closely with
him over the years and sought first hand
has outstanding skills at work he was
highly regarded and respected in our
community personally I will miss him
very much and our thoughts are with his
wife Helen and family at the same time
rest in peace Peter public memorial
service for Peter will be held this
coming Monday the 11th of September at 2
o'clock at the regular Town Hall council
also acknowledged the passing of former
councillor john chavis a moment silence
was held for both Peter and John air
that respect for him Council received a
report on a number of other issues
including approving speed changes and we
seek our way around a Hoka Road and
links to the new article around butchers
Road skew bridge and Ellie Terrace we
also discussed water supply issues and
West Asian in Summer Hill
providing a backup well and the
possibility of the points road scheme
joining the water advisory groups in the
community will be consulted on these
proposals
a project I've been involved with might
in my portfolio of town center
promotions as high street feature
lighting I'm very pleased that this was
approved and we'll see feature lighting
installed before the lead-up to the
Christmas period the project means that
the trees will be lit in different
colors for example Christmas themed
colors or maybe green for some Patrick's
Day this proposal has also been strongly
supported by the renderer ish the
community board regular promotions and
other local retailers also wanted to see
a solution on theme lighting for some
time so it's great this has been given
approval also approved with stage one of
the feature lighting for carboy town
center and the regeneration zone and
carboy option 2 was adopted as the
preferred option this follows a
community consultation process defectors
that kiss Street will be closed and
jolly Street reinstated staff has been
requested to repeal report on an
alternative configuration of the
proposed dog park in the evenings
facility also discussed and approved was
the ceiling of barça's Road by way of a
targeted rate before approving thus the
public consultation process and hearing
was held
it was a very productive council nation
where a number of maintenance we
discussed
[Music]